you said it's it's really dangerous when  the government can arbitrarily and  capriciously go in and shut down schools  and shut down businesses and raid your  home and  wield all sorts of power against you  outside of the rule of law and outside  of the American tradition I suppose I  would have to ask you which side is  doing that for the past two and a half  years the Democrats wielded that kind of  power against the entire American people  and they used the covid-19 as the excuse  for it now I still don't know what the  excuse is to lock down certain schools  and to impose these sorts of measures  and just a week ago the FBI raided  Donald Trump's home and and in an  absolutely unprecedented display of  arbitrary capricious political power so  this is a theme that I'm noticing coming  up with a lot of these callers the  things that you were accusing your  opponents of doing your own side is  doing  exclusively in this case